there are plenty of ferries still going
to france but there are a few passengers
to ferry
at dover the boats almost outnumber the
cars
that was all supposed to change on
monday but with the need to quarantine
on return now remaining so too will the
lack of traffic
ian marcroft booked a holiday in france
with his family for later this month
on the basis the fully vaccinated could
avoid quarantine when coming home
but he's now been forced to cancel this
has happened in
such a short period of time and the
government don't seem to be able to
act in a proactive manner that gives
people enough time to be able to plan
all these things
especially when you've got a lot of you
know loops that you've got to jump
through pcr testing
you've got to get those in place you've
got to get certificates uploaded to
portals
and make sure that you've got everything
all the relevant paperwork to do
everything
it's just massively frustrating for
people
there'll be thousands in the same
position as ian with travel firms
equally frustrated
hopes of a recovery for the industry are
once again put on hold
the problem is when you have these
fairly arbitrary changes coming in a
very short notice it has a very bad
impact
on public the public's confidence in
taking overseas holidays
the government needs to give some
financial assistance to the travel
industry we've had
very little part of accessing the
furlough scheme which has been for all
industries
and we've been by far the worst affected
to add to the chaos and confusion
france has imposed new rules of its own
for those going the other way
for anyone who is still planning on
crossing the channel by whatever means
they now require proof of a negative pcr
test done no more than
24 hours before departure it used to be
48 hours
and with those tests that now still need
to be done on return
it makes for an expensive trip the
government here says it's concerned
about cases of the beta variant in
france
the mutation first identified in south
africa
it accounts for less than 10 percent of
cases there while daily infections are
well below uk levels
but some scientists think ministers are
right to be wary
as the beta variant may be more
resistant to vaccines
you have to be careful about introducing
more inputs into this mixing pot
of the uk with these surging numbers of
infections
and you may see uh international
recombinations of this virus
going forward into the winter and of
course when flu and other respiratory
viruses come back
as well as the cold winter months more
buddhism mortalities that we see every
year as well
this could make the season the winter
season very difficult for the nhs
so just as some were hoping to surge out
of the uk barriers have reappeared
in some ways our nearest neighbor has
never seemed so far away
iva bennett sky news dover